to help fight stress of upcoming finals
colleges are using therapy llamas
University of South Florida and Radford
University are trucking in llamas and
other beasts to help students cope so
this is great for the students poor
things
but what about the llamas who have to
absorb the noxious annoying angst of
fragile idlers as they moan about
they're insulated existence and perhaps
the easiest phase of their comfy lives
yeah some studies show that pets lowers
stress but what about the stress of the
pet talk about torture imagine being a
llama and your bust miles from the
comforts of a pleasant petting zoo only
had some whiny bozo with issues running
their bony stinky fingers through your
gorgeous fur imagine a poor bunny yeah
they're using bunnies to force this sit
on the lap of a Gender Studies major
griping about our studying is really cut
into our social justice puppetry theater
I put these critters on suicide watch
because if I were in alpaca guinea pig
or a slow loris I'd hurl myself into
traffic before becoming a stress sponge
for these pampered slackers and where
will this end anyway when these precious
pupils graduate how will they handle the
real world will llamas accompany you to
a job interview yeah that'll go over
well well unless it's this one
[Music]
see my stress levels have already
plummeted thanks Lorenzo is that a real
block it is a real block Kimberly and
I'm going to you first isn't this animal
abuse the poor llamas are having a good
time they got to sit there be petted by
like neurotic kids yes spit viciously I
can really if you get too close and try
to mess with it so this might be the
llamas revenge this is - yeah it's
really I think it's not good it might be
like no but you know what you do you go
there they spit you have them spit on
your driver's license and it's
dominating you let him do this I don't
know animal abuse oh I had a very
different college experience yes I have
no doze and finals I just popped nodos
do you remember those pills yeah you had
speedy you know my address
I never tried one of those I was too
afraid yeah the paternity brothers
haven't stolen the llamas and going like
drank with it I do not regularly beat
them up I'm not even allowed on the
campuses are most college students are
now becoming more conservative more
libertarian because the rebelling
against the social justice there are the
new rebels excuse me where did you go to
college UC Davis now we used to be norm
I don't know what happened I just think
college is pretty competitive and even
to get into Berkeley you got to be
really good and then to succeed why are
you making them into snow here you know
what it is I see what you're saying wine
you know that the Democratic Party needs
Lamas Trump is breaking the brain yes
and so you need to Pama llama in Bama
IAT actually I think it's I think it's
fine let him have the pet show next
weekend really an exclusive long
exclusive
I'm going to talk to one of these law
professors do social media with Alam is
like I gonna get a job in the future if
they're like hanging out with llamas and
needing comfort and stress reduction
you've spit all over your face no one
wants you yeah if you went too
conservative you they'd cut that lime up
into steaks that's what they do you know
what I hope so